I want to ask uh at my home my mom is a
Shafi and my baba is Hanafia.
Um
is it enough for me or even for us to
believe that being a Muslim means
believing in the meaning of the shahada?
Just believe in Allah as the only god
and prophet Muhammad as the messenger
without follow any mab. Thank you.
>> The sister asked the question that the
father is the shafi and the mother is
hanafi. Correct or
>> my mother is shafi.
>> mother is shafi and father
>> my baba is hanafi. Even if your father
is Shafi and motherf
>> in Islam,
if you read the Quran, there is no Shafi
mentioned in the Quran and there is no
Hanfi mentioned in the Quran.
>> It's
>> if you wait, you ask the question, let
me give the reply.
>> Okay. If you read the hadith of Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam, there's no
say hadith that I know in which it is
mentioned
humbly. All these four, Imam, Imam Abu
Hanifh, Imam Malik, Imam Shafi, Imam
Ahmed Humb, they were great. They were
great scholars. We should love them and
respect them. All were great scholars.
They never came to divide the religion.
They came to simplify the religion.
All these folks were great scholars
and they were great imams.
They never came to make a new religion
or a new sect.
Yes, they analyze. One thing you have to
realize that all these four they were
great scholars more than 95% they are
same.
They might differ in 2% 5% here here or
there
and all the major aspects where it comes
to
etc. They are common. They may differ in
certain aspects of faith. Generally all
these four they are great scholars.
All of them say you should pray five
times. All of them speak about all say
give zakat 2.5%. They may differ little
bit here or there if there is scope of
difference
in the major aspects. It's very clear in
the major ga kabira or major far they
are common. They may differ in small
aspects also. You have to pray salah.
Okay. One may say keep your hand on top,
one may say down. These are small
aspects. No one says that whether you
keep your hand on top or down your your
salah gets nullified.
Correct? So we as Muslim Allah says in
the Quran in surah Imran 3 verse number
103,
hold strongly to the group to the rope
of Allah and be not divided. The rope of
Allah is the glorious Quran and say
glorious Quran and as far as fik is
concerned there is aulik
and because the usul of fick differs
between these four the answer may differ
all these are great scholars for example
for example
if I ask you the question
that 2 multiply by 3
- 10 / 4 into brackets 3 into 5 bracket
close into two. What is the answer?
>> Who knows the formula how to solve it?
Anyone knows the formula?
>> Sorry.
Huh?
>> Correct.
bracket first then
no
there is a formula I think you forgot in
school we learned board mass
board mass brackets of first then
division then multiplication
then addition then subscription
but if someone comes with a new formula
I want to do multiplication first the
answer will be different so if the
formula differs
The answers differ. The equation is the
same. Correct. Right or wrong? So body
mass is a formula that the mass sh is
correct. But you may come up with a new
formula. So in fick
in all the four schools of thought the f
number one is that Quran is highest
number one. Then comes
the mutawat hadith.
Number two is mutawat hadith means those
hadith which have come in multiple
chains one after the other multiple
times. After that it may differ. Some f
may say we want to believe in a sai
hadith. Some people may say we want to
believe in orf custom.
So if it differs the final answer may
differ a little bit. So the difference
is not because they are not
knowledgeable. It's the difference in
usul of
and this troubled me for a long time.
It's not that oh they don't believe in
hadith. No it's not like that. If the
usul differs most of the answers will be
same because the top two three criteria
are the same. So if it differs sometimes
it may be differing because of lack of
mercy because of wool of sometimes it
may differ because of lack of knowledge
one group of scholar may say it's a sai
hadith the other may say it's z hadith
so based on that it may differ but
generally in the major issues there is
no problem so that the reason the
scholars say that if you follow one
school of thought
and if you're an average common man who
doesn't have knowledge, you stick to
one, no problem. But if you are a
student of knowledge
or if you have a capacity totihad,
then you can choose. But whatever you
do, these differences between the four
schools of thought, they are not major
differences, they're minor differences.
So we Muslims should not fight over it.
Regarding, you ask me the question,
should you follow your father or should
you follow your mother? I would say
follow prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam.
Abu Hanifh also said follow the prophet.
Imam Shafi also said that all the four I
amma said if you find any of my fatwa
which goes against Allah in his rasool
throw my fatwa on the wall. All the
four, all the four Immu Hanifh, Imam
Malik, Imam Shafi, Im Ahmed Nal, all
four said if you find any of my fatwa
which goes against the Quran, Allah and
the rasool any say hadith throw my fatwa
that means they gave their verdict but
they're human beings they can make
mistakes. So tomorrow if you find that I
made a mistake and you find a Quranic
verse which is against what I'm saying
of course Quran is better than me.
If you find a hadith which I did not
know it's a Sai hadith. So all these
scholars came to make life easy for us
not difficult. But the followers
unfortunately they fight with one
another.
If you ask me what am I? I say I'm a
Muslim.
Quran in several places says
say that I'm a Muslim in Iran 3:64
verse number 33
say that I'm a Muslim say that I'm a
Muslim no say say I'm say I'm a shafi
say I'm humbly say I'm a maliki if
someone says that I have no problem but
don't fight over It
you understand now we should love all
the air
I may have a different I have done
research correct and my formula is that
when you do research I do research I
saying that okay keeping hand on the
chest now one person keep the hand below
the navl
I did my research he did my research you
want to have an academic argument have
no problem but don't fight in public and
once you do research you stick to a
research
I feel keeping the hands on the chest is
sah it's absel but that doesn't mean
keeping the hand below the navl is haram
your salah will not break it's a
question of which is absel which is
better which is mustab so I do my
research I find it's keeping on the
chest I will give you reference
I'll give you references but if someone
doesn't agree no problem the major issue
is pray so don't if you're having a
debate where to keep it have a debate
whether you should pray or not. Correct.
Now there are thousands of Muslims are
not praying. Now you want to fight over
where to keep your hand. Okay. Academic
wise good. But there are millions of
Muslims not praying salah. So give a
lecture on praying salah. Not where to
keep the hand. Do you understand?
That doesn't mean that you neglect the
academics.
I am very
I am very strict
in my personal life. I'm very strict. I
wear trousers above the ankle.
very strict where the cap keeper very
strict I do my research I stick to it
but my lectures on broader aspects
it's on broader aspects I gave a lecture
on salah day for yesterday I didn't talk
about that I talked about how to get
people to offer salah
and whether shafi you have to pray five
times a day you have to fast well in the
full month of Ramadan you have to pay
zakat there may be little bit difference
here or there if there's Friends, Allah
says in the Quran in Surah 4:59,
obey Allah and obey the messenger and
those
the scholars. But if they differ, go
back to Allah and his if they differ,
you do research or if you're not
qualified, you ask another scholar.
If you're qualified, you can do your
own. If you're not qualified and as long
as you follow a a reliable scholar, it's
accepted.
Where you have to be very careful is in
the questions of
the questions of is a lesser issue in
question of a that you have to have
properly. That's important.
You worship Allah don't worship somebody
else besides Allah. So these are very
critical things
that see to it that you worship Allah.
You don't worship anyone else besides
Allah. See to it you don't break any
rules of
these are the major issues. But the
issues of f do research no problem.
And I my solution is most of the people
said I am only right.
I am only right. Now when you say I am
only right
there may be a conflict. What I say I am
also right. When I say I am also right
doesn't mean that you're also right. You
may be right, may be wrong. I don't
know. We'll discuss tomorrow. When I say
I am also right, I'm not antagonizing.
When I say I am only right, that means
you're saying the other person is wrong
if he doesn't listen to you. When I'm
saying I am also right, that means I'm
sure I've done my research. You are
right or wrong. We'll discuss tomorrow.
So this is a better way to prevent the
conflict than to argue on the small
issues which are issues of mustab sunnah
absel. So whether issues of aalat
we should not argue so much you can do
research follow it but is not the
question to fight over it. The question
more to fight is are you offering salah
or not? Are you giving zakat or not? Are
you fasting in the month of Ramadan? No.
Hope that answers the question, sister.